today we're talking about how gta 4 and
red dead redemption almost got remasters
and how call of duty is just leaking all
over the place
rockstar insider tez 2 recently claimed
on twitter that it is unlikely that
rockstar games is moving forward with
potential gta 4 and red dead redemption
remasters this is possibly due to the
poor reception of last year's gta the
trilogy the definitive edition in a
tweet replying to another user on
twitter tez 2 also clarified that the
remasters weren't in full production
more just something was planned with
rockstar looking at the trilogy to green
light more remasters a subsequent report
from kotaku cooperates that neither of
these remasters are moving forward for
now and that all remakes are being
shelved as the studio focuses on wait
for it wait for it
gta 6
not 5 again
6. when the trilogy launched back in
november it wasn't in a particularly
good state here at gamespot we gave the
gta trilogy a 4 out of 10 noting the
absolutely hideous character models game
breaking bugs and a number of missing
features things were so bad that the
original versions of the game were
reinstated on pc and modders swooped in
to fix the bugs before rockstar managed
to do so itself despite this earlier
this year publisher take 2 did note that
the trilogy significantly exceeded the
company's expectations with estimations
of around 10 million units being sold
but okay i'll admit it i really wanted a
gta 4 remaster and i still kind of want
a gta 4 remaster now i haven't played it
on console in a long time but i have
recently played it on pc
and it still holds up so i have no idea
why i think it needs a remaster like
it's fine
but i want it but enough of my wants
let's switch gears to some fps news new
call of duty images that we won't be
showing here have surfaced online the
images seem to be a mix of screens from
this year's modern warfare 2 and an
unannounced game from treyarch the
developers of black ops these leaked
picks are the result of data mining from
a recent warzone mobile update and fans
have already begun to speculate one of
the images that seems to be catching the
most attention is labeled stealth this
is because it contains an f-117
nighthawk a stealth aircraft that's
become synonymous with the gulf war so
when do call of duty fans think the next
game will take place
during the gulf war i just said it pay
attention this video is worth 50 percent
of your grade actually that might be a
little too high considering this is all
just speculation after all nothing has
been confirmed by activision or treyarch
and at this point the copyright claims
are the only clues that these images
might be the real deal so let me know in
the comments if you want a sequel to
cold war during the gulf war or if you
want black ops to do something totally
different and speaking of doing things
differently beginning in october games
with gold will no longer offer xbox 360
games word of the change first surfaced
in an email sent out to dutch xbox live
gold subscribers xbox one games however
will still be available each month xbox
360 games with gold will still be
available for a re-download regardless
of your membership the program was
originally introduced in 2013 for xbox
360 consoles and expanded to xbox one
consoles in 2014 as a bonus for xbox
live gold subscribers so are you going
to miss the 360 games each month or has
game pass just completely taken over
your heart and you couldn't care less
about this change
i'm in the second boat but let me know
where you are and i'll see you tomorrow
you